chad is with us in oklahoma i chat
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show I have a
car that's paid for I have a van that's
paid for they're only worth you know
1,500 for the van maybe 1500 for the car
I have a motorcycle that's paid for
maybe worth eight thousand I saved
$3,500 so that's the good news the bad
news is I recently received a
garnishment from my employer and told me
some bad news and I thought maybe I
heard a you know damaged a car or
something but anyhow I have $3,500 saved
I did what you said you know if you were
telling everybody to do the debt
collector calls or what have you need it
see if they can settle so I talked him
down from $5,000 it's a thirty five
fifteen however I've been trying not
happy with that because it took about
four and a half months to save that
$3,500 so back in 2015 this is when the
when I had the credit card maxed out
from and then of course I had three
others that I maxed out also in 2015
what would you do if you're in my shoes
show you this is a $5,000 credit card
debt yeah it was originally the it was
$2,000 but of course you know you have
fees and what-have-you so I'm not mad
I'm just you know I'm come a little
dismayed I mean the fact that you see
your money just going and and of course
it really tell you through technically
it wasn't really my money to begin with
you know with this $3,500 but I was
thinking to sell the motorcycle go ahead
and you know I don't know do I file
bankruptcy or I mean is it's bankruptcy
such a big
skill because I can I was trying to buy
a homage gonna I've already been
pre-approved for a home and I figured
maybe a sixty thousand dollar home would
be suitable for me instead of paying
rent yeah you know you know I don't need
to buy a home you have a bunch of bad
debt outstanding and if you got
pre-approved at a substandard interest
rate you need to go clean up your debts
and build an emergency fund of three to
six on those expenses so buying a home
is off the table right now no you're not
bankrupt you have the money to pay your
bills you just don't like it no I don't
like it at all when you rent you ran the
bills up I did Heather your bills I mean
you took stuff out of a store and put on
that credit card whoa
you know so pay the bill I mean that's
I'm sorry that's where you are and
you're settling 5,000 our debt for
thirty five hundred that's 70 cents on
the dollar it's not great but it's okay
and in the good and the bad news is they
got you over a barrel because this
garnishment and you need to get your
wages back to get rid of the rest of
this stuff so yeah I'm getting this in
writing from them do not give them
electronic access to your checking
account you send a wire or a certified
check or something else to them in order
to you know in order to settle this once
you've gotten it in writing and yeah you
do need to sell the motorcycle you don't
need a toy in the garage worth more than
your two cars combined while you're
trying to get your finances straightened
out so yeah I mean you can get a nothing
of the motorcycle later but um yeah I'm
getting rid of that thing that'll put
some of the cash back in the bank and
then let's go get those other debts that
are outstanding and start cleaning them
up one at a time become debt-free and
then have an emergency fund of three to
six months of expenses and then start
saving a down payment for your house and
that then the house will be a blessing
but you know at some points in the last
two to three years you've been out of
control several times and you guys get
you got to get this thing where it's
running down the middle of the road
again your life that is and you feel the
steadiness of that and then you'll be
ready to start talking about bond house